alors j'ai une petite interview pour toi
plus que les sujets il était réservé
pour toi un an de jean tuba et le
portrait chinois le portrait chinois
c'est quand on dit à quelqu'un s'il
était une fleur qu'elle flirte eu le
meilleur de toi c'est très con alors moi
j'étais préparé une petite interview
spéciale c'est l'anti portrait chinois
si c'était une injure l'open trop si tu
étais un collabo l'open ouais si c'était
une maladie le pen l'a loupé lite elle a
lepénisé d'un accident enfin je tire
bois ouais si tu étais un insecte
j'avais lu un truc un moustique
oui c'est sûr enfin nous mêmes qui
transporte du mal à 10,1
pire que tout elle est une perversion du
srec wacom perversion catholique
c'était une arme crayon était un bouton
de brian c'était un super supplice de
lire le présent
ouais c'était un raciste toujours
paraître jean-marie changer et si tu
étais un immigré serait mon fils c'est
tout comme